Circular knitting on the Titexma TH/TR 160
has one more step than
some other machines.
The secret to circular or tubular knitting
on any machine is to understand
the slip settings on each bed.
The difference with this machine is
that it only has one slip
setting on the main bed.
With the carriage set in this position,
the carriage will slip in both directions.
On the ribber,
you can choose to slip
in only one direction.
Get started in circular knitting on this
machine with both beds
set for plain knitting.
Cast on and knit full needle rib
with all needles in work on both beds.
Make sure the ribber is racked to "H" so
the needles aren't crashing
into each other, and knit a few rows.
End with your carriage on the right.
For the first row of circular knitting.
Leave the main bed carriage set for plain.
The change lever will be set to plane
and the side cam levers are set on "N".
On the ribber,
set it to slip left by putting the left
side cam lever to print and make
sure the tuck lever is set on "R".
In this example, the ribber will slip
as you pass the carriage to the left.
So knit across and only
the main bed stitches will knit.
Now, keeping those ribber settings
the same throughout the whole piece,
move the main bed change lever to "part",
knit to the right.
Only the ribber needles will knit.
You'll repeat rows 1 and 2
for circular knitting
and you'll change the main bed setting
every other row, keeping the ribber
setting the same throughout.
Row 1, your main bed
carriage is set to plain.
You knit to the left and you'll
knit the main bed only.
Row 2, the main bed carriage is set
to part and you'll knit to the right,
and ribber stitches will knit only.
So you'll change that main bed setting
every other row from part to plane,
part to plain every other row.
With circular knitting,
you're alternating knitting on the ribber
and knitting on the main bed,
forming a tube.